welcome to the live stream
Anthony scaramouche II lasting what
barely a week and a half we're gonna dig
into the hilarious and and really quite
sad actually firing of the new and
already former White House
communications director Anthony
scaramouche II I'll be taking their
questions we're gonna get into a whole
bunch of different stuff so I'm glad
that you are with me on this live stream
I will also preview what's happening on
the David Pakman show tomorrow which I
think many of you will like and if
history is any indication many of you
will not like and will at least threaten
to never watch again but that happens
with almost everything we do so
hopefully there will be enough of you
that will like what we are gonna do
tomorrow on the program but I will talk
to you about that a little bit later
let's talk about what's going on during
this live stream if this is your first
live stream live streams are live during
the time which they are live you can
also watch them after the fact and that
I'm told is about 95 percent as
compelling as watching it live super
chat is on if you have questions you
want me to answer if you have comments
that you want me to read and address use
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window and I will get those
questions and comments and we will make
them part of the live stream and include
you in it it's a beautiful thing with
peace and love super chat also new
members and patrons who sign up or
pledge during the live stream will get
live thank-yous and shout outs from me I
will sing your praises I will talk about
what an amazing person you are and how
you are quite literally a savior of
independent media etc etc so membership
and patronage just as a preview the
challenge today is 1860 patrons okay
last stream we failed to achieve the
target number of patrons to trigger a
56% discounted membership so I'll put it
out there now because I do actually want
to have a successful stream as far as
this goes
if we hit
60 patrons this stream I will create and
announce just for you great people on
the live stream a coupon code to get 56
percent off of membership last time we
did this it was 55 percent off I am
willing to best that with a 56 percent
discount code if we get to 1860 patrons
and lastly obvious trolling and hate is
going to get you banned if it's not
obvious if it's not obvious trolling and
hate it probably won't get you banned
and along those lines
moderators clarf 1 2 3 4 longtime super
chatter clarf 1 2 3 4 told me that he or
she was banned from sending I don't I
don't understand if it's all comments or
just super chats but please Clark 1 2 3
4 is a longtime super chatter I don't
know why they would have been banned but
please unban them I'm not exactly sure
how to do it myself or I already would
have
but please unban cloth 1 2 3 4 and yeah
that is my only message and as far as as
far as moderation goes okay so get the
super chats in and get the memberships
in get the patreon donations in and I'll
jump into the content on the program
today I said that the firing of Reince
Priebus was all great for scaramouche E
and Trump while they're on the same page
but that those two personalities as soon
as they start to clash could go
completely nuclear and it could be
really bad for everybody and indeed that
has already happened Anthony scaramouche
E has already been fired and it is
hilarious and it is sad and the amount
of really the amount of destruction that
Anthony scaramouche E has already caused
is pretty stunning he was in ten days
his hiring triggered the resignation of
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
who I mean in his defense he could have
left at any point he was being asked to
defend the indefensible from day one of
the Trump administration in any case of
scaramouche Ian Spicer out Spicer leaves
scaramouche E comes in and
immediately start saying Reince Priebus
can defend himself if he's gonna argue
he's not the leaker I'll fire whoever I
need to except for myself and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders gave this bizarre
interview to reporter Ryan Lizza
where he argued that Steven Bannon
wanted to perform oral sex on himself
which is in the scope of things that are
discussed by directors of White House
communications some choose to focus on
foreign policies some choose to focus on
press freedom
Anthony scaramouche II making his name
in his short-lived 10 days as what
direct white director of White House
communications for his commentary on
self fulfilling our Moochie will be
known for and so he comes in
Spicer's out Priebus is out now
scaramouche II himself is now and what
did he accomplish
he missed the birth of his own child
last week was did not even see his new
newly born child for days apparently
because he was tied up with Trump his
wife is divorcing him because of this
what she finds to be out of out of
control
out of this world loyalty to Donald
Trump and now scaramouche II himself is
out of a job and by the way the sale of
his fight financial firm has not yet to
a Chinese firm has not yet been approved
if Donald Trump wanted to do this and
it's unclear whether Trump would or
wouldn't do this but if Trump wanted to
end the the possibility of that sale and
and have the government not authorize it
that's probably something Trump could do
so that's going to be another
interesting aspect of this to follow and
just total destruction and and here's
the main thing I want to communicate to
you because every aspect of this was
pretty predictable Donald Trump did not
fire Anthony scaramouche II because he
figured out that oh wow scaramouche E is
just fundamentally someone who is
ideologically not
in line with my views or whatever the
case may be
Trump consulted with friends over the
weekend about whether scaramouche's
presence has sort of irreparably damaged
if scaramouche II had irreparable damage
to his own reputation and and we heard
that the new White House chief of staff
John Kelly indicated that he believes
that it is a bad idea to have
scaramouche be on so this was yet again
Trump just being influenced by the
people around him and trying to make the
best decision that came to mind at the
time but this is not indicative of Trump
buckling down and saying we're really
going to start singing a different tune
in general with our stuff it's not that
at all it's just Trump making the
decision he thinks at the time is best
for himself amidst just a general lack
of knowledge of anything so I don't
believe that
Scarah Moochie is going to be the last
guy to go and in fact it could be John
Kelly who says hey here's a list of
people that actually have to go and
still very uncertain is the future of
Attorney General Jeff Sessions which I
mentioned on the program today Jeff
Sessions is one of trumps last links to
the mainline Republican Party
establishment Bannon is not not part of
that
scaramouche II wasn't but now he's gone
we are going to see potentially if
sessions goes and I'm telling you I hope
Jeff Sessions doesn't resign and makes
Trump fire him if that's what he wants
although maybe that's blowing over it's
not really clear I really hope that then
Republicans in the Senate and in the
house will feel more free to just say no
to Trump because they presumably will
not have any more of this loyalty to
their mainstream members that are still
part of this Trump team I don't know I
think there's a good chance that that
could happen so chaos absolute and total
chaos and the Trump administration and
as I mentioned today all of this chaos
could well make Trump more and more
erratic and make him take action I would
say top candidate right now is North
Korea maybe an escalation would sear
maybe an escalation with Iran that's
really what I'm worried about in most
ways having Donald Trump in power I
believe is better than Trump leaving and
having Mike Pence in power because the
scandal would stop with pence and we
would see a straight and bi straight I
don't mean homophobic although I I do
mean that otherwise I wasn't referring
to him to that though sort of straight
right-wing ideological religious
conservative policy platform fewer
scandals and probably a lot more damage
done to the country Trump is doing major
damage in terms of the reputation of the
US around the world but he's not getting
a lot done the one area where I would
trust pence more than Trump is not to
haphazardly bomb someone because he's
tanking and the heat is closing in on
Russia and the heat is closing in on so
many of these other areas so watch for
all of those things okay let's get into
the super chat a lot of super chat
questions number one from Bailey
Marshall
do you have an episode on socialism
coming how about F P okay the episode on
social by the way what is FP financial
planning or foreign policy probably
foreign policy we have a long form deep
dive on socialism and Marxism and
communism that is in the works I am
almost ready to record the narration for
it and then producer Noah Ferguson is
gonna get started on the editing it's
going to be a tremendous piece it will
likely go live on YouTube during our a
summer vacation which is going to start
the week of August 14th that's the start
of our summer vacation we've got a bunch
of really good stuff planned for you
guys and I want to keep doing the
long-form pieces Bailey who sent the $2
super Chad Bailey Marshall I may have in
my excitement about talking about this
piece I might have forgotten to mention
that Bailey we have a lot of long-form
pieces coming and that's why we're
talking about growing our financial
support our base through patreon and
membership gr has sent a $5 super chat
mr. Deasy the PAC matriot easy you're
the one with the words your platform
makes the ladies swoon and ger is it
true the rebus didn't cut the
Jesus as far as I know rinse Priebus
would that flatulence was not a factor
flatulence was not a factor gr in the
firing of Reince Priebus leo men has
sent a five-dollar super chat with no
question or comment thanks very much
floppy kid has sent the 10 Canadian
dollar super chat overly puritanical and
entrenched progressives danger towards
2018 and 2020 elections in my opinion
your thoughts the type who'd cut off
their face to spite their nose you know
floppy you'd have to tell me a little
more about what issues you think these
puritanical and trenched progressives
pose a danger in 2018 and 2020 I've been
super clear that the illiberal
progressive wing which is not huge but
it is there is a problem for the
Democratic Party in 2018 and 2020 but
corporate Democrats what I call
Democrats Inc are also a major problem
for 2018 and 2020 and I applauded today
on the show Bernie Sanders saying he
will be putting out sponsoring a bill
for Medicare for all single single payer
but we've had HR 676 Medicare for all in
the house for years and most recently in
this legislative session since January
and it really doesn't matter unless the
Democratic Party is willing to say our
platform now is Medicare for all that is
what the Democratic Party needs to do in
my opinion gee are sending another $5
Super Shot super chat saying Skaar mooch
easy don't let the doors he hit you in
the hindquarters ease on the way out
doors these fix the VA Trump nasty
Pakman I've missed you love gr all right
well gr back in the swing of things on
an absolutely ferocious tear already
early in this live stream Isiah Rowe has
sent a ten dollar super Chad my dad
argues that all the chaos and firings
are continued slob training and that
Trump is a fighter for the people being
held back by the establishment and
traitors yet that's quite that that's
for some pretty significant cognitive
dissonance there Isaiah
however it's funny that the the the
swamp training is happening because
Trump has started firing the people he's
hired right so it's hilarious that the
only evidence I've seen of Trump
the swamp is getting rid of some of the
people he filled the swamp with himself
I think it's uh it's quite a hypothesis
I sail Isaiah let's leave it at that
Quin Maliki has sent the five dollar
super chat might you a self-described
Social Democrat debate or talk
ideological positions and real
alternatives to corporate ism with a
socialist like Richard Wolff Richard
Wolff was my economics professor at the
University of Massachusetts I have
talked about ideological positions and
alternatives to corporate ism with
Richard Wolff he's been on the program
15 or 20 times maybe even more so check
out some of those archives Quinn
hopefully you'll like those the needle
drop the infamous Anthony Fantana
sending a $20 super chat hey David sorry
I haven't gotten my schedule together
for a collaboration I'm messing up
you're still killing it though thank you
for all the content and thoughts you're
the best I love the vegan dessert
segment keep it up so listen I actually
I'm glad Anthony is here because there
is just I it's an indescribable and in
fact if I can somehow find the link to
it although I'm never able to let me see
here if I search my email for pat vegan
I might be able to find it yeah vegan
birthday there is an incredible video
that is out there on YouTube and I don't
actually understand I was told that the
person who made this video is your
editor Anthony and I don't even know if
that's true I've just pasted the link to
this video in the description to the
live stream this is a video it is a sort
of I don't even know it's like a remix
of sorts of the day that we did a vegan
dessert tasting for a vegan producer Pat
Forde on the show and I honestly don't
know if this video has anything to do
with the needle drop in Anthony
fantana's channel but I heard that the
editor for Anthony's channel put this
together it's stunning okay absolutely
stunning one of the best show related
user-generated pieces of content that
I've seen it's a youtube poop okay I
don't know what that means
are you saying it's [ __ ] or oh they
yes he's my editor he's a young kid from
Brazil okay well listen this kid's got
upper management written all over him
let me put it that way check out the
link that I've put in the description
for the YouTube video check that out
alright Anthony thank you for checking
in Tina Howard sent the $5 to super chat
david politican was this weekend do you
plan to attend next year you would be a
great voice there listen if I was asked
to appear I probably would I have mixed
thoughts about what we saw at politican
I mean there was there was a lot of
nonsense and also some interesting
debate and some interesting
conversations a lot of it felt just kind
of forced I don't know how to describe
it but yeah I would go I would certainly
go the tie would have gone this year
actually but the timing just didn't work
out whether I have a big trip coming up
and a small trip next week kind of just
I can't be traveling all the time and so
it just did not work this year but Tina
I would be interested in exploring that
okay let me get into some thank yous
here because we've got a lot going on as
you may know the YouTube channel for the
David Pakman show has experienced a
precipitous drop in ad revenue we had a
very strong start at the beginning of
the year as indicated by the number one
on this chart the YouTube ad boycott hit
on March 31st and we lost 99% of our ad
revenue as indicated by the number two
we thought we were in recovery phase in
mid-may and into early June as indicated
by the number three and at the end of
June the beginning of July at the number
for YouTube ad revenue fell off a cliff
now I'm gonna be totally clear with you
I don't want to change thing about what
we're doing at the David Pakman show
we've got half a dozen more long-form
pieces planned we've got investigative
reporting plan we've got some in the
field stuff planned but all of that
stuff takes more staff hours and what I
want to do rather than have to come to
you and say I hate giving the audience
bad news and I don't want to come to you
and say hey we're not going to be able
to do a B and C what we're trying to do
is just make up for the lost revenue and
then we can laugh our way back to
sticking to the original plan and say
doesn't matter what
with the YouTube ad boycott so one thing
you can do is sign up for membership at
david pakman.com slash membership when
you go to that website you can select
whatever membership you want monthly or
yearly and then when you click the red
sign up button you'll be taken to a page
with something called the coupon code
field and in that field if you choose to
enter the coupon code I voted 17 you
will get a 40% discount and John
Greenlee has just signed up John D
Greenlee I should say has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership Stacy
Costello has just signed up and Alice
Hayes has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership now if a 40%
discount is not enough for you I've got
another proposal for you
if you go to patreon.com/scishow
we're 1848 of you now we're pledging at
least $1.00 a month we are targeting
1860 patrons by the end of this live
stream if we get there I will create and
release a custom coupon code for
membership for you I will only announce
it here on this live stream and it will
be a 56% discount code now before I do
the the patreon thank-yous why 56% to
live streams ago I made this proposal
and said if we get to 1,800 patrons I
will create a 55 percent discount code
just to keep it going and keep it
interesting this time I will bet I will
best that and create a 56 percent
discount code if we get to 1860 patrons
by the end of the stream we started at
1848 however the good news is that since
then amanda martinez has made a $5 a
month pledge and Richard AB Gil V has
made a $2.00 a month pledge so we're
already closing in we're all we're only
20 minutes into this thing not even and
we are already closing in to that target
of 1860 patrons we are 11 away 11 away
okay so please help us make that happen
it really does support the work that we
do
we're trying to turn it into something
interesting a little contest going on
Morgan ray Hess Studios has sent a
five-dollar super chat saying first of
all David thanks so much for continuing
to be compassionate and respectful to
everyone even now it's quite difficult
for me especially now well thanks very
much Morgan Ray has studios I appreciate
that
gr has sent another $10 super chat and
they they are becoming increasingly
incoherent real talk Pakman Kwame
Kilpatrick former Detroit mayor has
extremely high numbers of support to
this day in the in the D I assume that
means in Detroit
despite robbing us blind do you know his
story can you relate it to Trump nasty
III can't really know I can I don't
think that I'm equipped to do that right
now gr but it's absolutely something
I'll look into and if I'm able to relate
that story you can be certain that that
I will gr has sent a $2 super chat it
was time for some real talk people love
gr okay Daniel Sullivan has sent a $5
super Chad I'm aware that you don't
support BDS the boycott divestment
sanctions movement but I'd like to get
your take on the Israel anti-boycott act
that was introduced in the Senate back
in March I've got a story coming up on
that Daniel so I am going to be talking
about that I mean so my principles are I
am against the BDS movement I am in
favor of free speech so we will we will
dig into that in more detail upcoming on
an episode of the David Pakman show very
very important issue
Morgan Ray Hess Studios has sent a $5
Super chat now to my question I am of
the opinion that the right is now so
radicalized that we will have to
organize to clear its rhetoric from our
culture thoughts well the right isn't is
extremely radicalized and this is why
even a very clear Republican like John
McCain is a Republican there's no
mistaking him for a progressive and
there's no mistaking him for a
a moderate Democrat John McCain is a
Republican but his views partially
because the Democratic Party has moved
quite a bit to the right are probably
more at home as a Joe Manchin type
Democrat than in the Republican Party so
I don't know that it's that the rights
radicalization is what has made it so
entrenched in our culture it is the fact
that our elected officials are way more
right wing than the views of the
American electorate and I've talked
about this many times and this relates
to issues of health care this relates to
issues of Taxation there's a lot of
issues where this applies and it's a sad
thing because it would be great if our
elected officials sort of approximated
the political views of our electorate
but between gerrymandering and also
using wedge issues to raise
disproportionate amounts of money you
get an electorate that that is far to
the left on most issues than our elected
officials okay
we've got a couple more Super chats here
eat KitKat Dumbledore now let's see I
skipped on saucy mix or has sent a
five-dollar super chat producer Pat says
can I get a bag of CH IPS yeah thats
related to check out the video that is
linked to at the top of the video
description for this livestream and that
is where that quote is from producer
passing can I get a bag of chips eat
KitKat double J has sent a two dollar
super chat David it's summer watch the
money come back at the beginning of
September listen I believe you know
there is a seasonality to revenue on
YouTube but we do seem to be
experiencing a sort of new normal of low
ad revenue and believe me the last thing
I would be doing if I thought genuinely
that ad revenue was going to fix itself
the last thing I would be doing is
putting the endless hours of effort into
fundraising and making up the lost money
I have every indication that this is
more or less than you normal
although there could well be an uptick
in September but the thing you're
forgetting
also is that typically you also have
more YouTube views in September so it's
it's sort of logical that if you have
more YouTube traffic you would make more
money that's a separate question from
how much are you making per view or
what's called revenue per thousand views
in the industry or whatever so yeah I
mean I think there's something to what
you're saying but it's it's certainly
not the solution gr has sent a sent
another $10 superjet gr is I think I
would venture to say gr is the the super
Chad all-star of July 31st
f me Pakman I got a new debit car my
patreon has been worthless lately
everyone gr is worthless but only until
this moment Pakman it's real tops on
sometimes it is DZ I love you love gr
okay gr maybe drinking tonight unclear
Nicholas Martin it's 10 euro super chat
love your show David thanks for being
the anti-venom shot I need after
watching Trump's speeches do you have a
favorite Democratic candidate you'd like
to see run in 2020 so on principle I'm
refusing to answer that question because
I believe it's too early to be talking
about 2020 case in point I don't know if
you've seen I've done two or three
stories recently about I always get the
name wrong it's not Canela and it's not
Kamala it's camp camel I don't know come
up camel Harris the Democratic senator
from California some elite Democratic
donors are already anointing her and I
think it's ridiculous I think anointing
candidates by giving them money three
years early is exactly how Democrats got
into this mess in this first place so
the last thing I'm gonna participate in
is talking about 2020 candidates we've
got a disaster on our hands and
Democrats need to take over the House
and Senate in 2018 that is where the
priority needs to be right now
Frank macwrite has sent the $20 super
chat longtime super chat all-star Frank
macwrite switched over from the full
show so you might have covered this but
can you talk about house key
Moochie and sh s's tick ticking on
calling his vulgar rant competitive to
now it being unbecoming for someone of
that office I have no idea who is s HS s
HS what does that stand for
Stoughton High School Sharon high school
what is SH s I genuinely don't know
secretary Oh Secretary of Homeland
Security right that makes sense yeah I
mean listen the funniest thing to me
about the entire talking about whether
Steve Bannon is trying to perform oral
sex Oh Sarah Huckabee Sanders right and
dick talking tick ticking on calling his
vulgar rant competitive to know how
becoming yeah I don't know how Sarah
Huckabee Sanders can square I don't know
how how could you send Sarah Huckabee
Sanders can look at herself in the
mirror any day in the same way that I
don't know how Spicer was able to do it
from day one it's an absolute joke and I
have not covered that yet Frank but I am
probably going to deal with that on the
program tomorrow it's absolutely
ridiculous and I think that she probably
will not go because she is able to in in
the eyes of a trumpet
sarah huckabee sanders has this demeanor
of unabashed confidence in absolutely
unbelievable nonsense that that's what
trumps Trump likes the optics of it are
exactly what Trump likes and I see her
she's good she's also got upper
management written all over her for and
I apologize for using that term twice
Athena Harding has sent a $10 super
check the tension with North Korea seems
to be in a death spiral what are your
thoughts about the recent icy BM tests
can we even avoid devolving into war at
this point yes so I talked about this on
the program today we've got a video
upcoming about it in fact it may have
just gone live at 6:00 Eastern I see the
biggest risk with North Korea
politically as Trump becoming desperate
and saying hey what's the best candidate
for a bombing right now or military
action and
going into North Korea that's a major
major concern for me right now i I think
military action in North Korea is
complex because you you would basically
be conceding that you're going to be
killing civilians and we're trying to
save the civilians sanctions will more
acutely starve more civilians so that is
also dicey and it's unclear how
effective it's going to be I think that
working the China angle needs to be
looked at in China even though it is
sort of North Korea's only Ally other
than former Chicago Bulls star rebounder
Dennis Rodman I still think that China
can have sense talked into it but not
from an increased increasingly
belligerent Trump who doesn't understand
how if our relationship goes bad with
China a ton of stuff gets way more
expensive in the United States I mean
it's just an absolute and total train
wreck to absolute and total train wreck
and I'm very worried about military
escalations with North Korea no doubt
about it okay let me do some thank-yous
to not fall behind on these the number
one way that the David Pakman show
exists I don't know how else to say it
like without membership there's no show
the show ends without membership is
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership i mentioned at the beginning
of the script of the stream we have a
coupon code available to you and that
coupon code is I vote at 17 I voted 17
all one word all lowercase which will
save you 40% we do a bonus show every
day just for our paid subscribers and
that is one of the great reasons to sign
up Simon Winn held has just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership Simon
thank you you are a tremendous person
directly supporting independent media
there has never been a more important
time to do that Amanda Martinez has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership amanda has also used the
coupon code I voted 17 and has saved 40%
off of that membership also I need to
say thanks to some new patreon patrons
we are trying to get to 1860 patrons by
the end of this live stream that is my
challenge to
if you can help me get to 1860 patrons
by the end of this livestream I will go
on to our website and create a coupon
code just for you
I will not announce this via email I
will not announce this on the David
Pakman show
I will not announce this on the podcast
and it will save you 56 percent off of
membership that would be the biggest
membership discount we will ever have
done but I need your help to get us to
1860 patrons and helping me do that are
anastasia who has just pledged two
dollars a month teresa Durkee has just
made a pledge of five dollars a month
Thank You Theresa Rob Bennett has just
bumped his pledge from two to five
dollars a month thanks Rob for making
that increase and Martin vandamm brand
has made a pledge of two dollars a month
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
so we are approaching 1860 we are now at
1852 folks I don't want to fail last
time we came we fell too short of our
target we're only eight away help make
it happen I would really really
appreciate that a lot of questions
coming in via super chat but before we
do that I will tell you this last
Tuesday we did an hour-long interview
with Dave Rubin host of the Reuben
report very controversial a lot of
people did not like some of the things
Dave Rubin had to say a lot of people
didn't feel that I was harsh enough
against Dave Rubin but as you know my
interview style is to ask questions not
to yell and the questions I was asking I
believe did expose some of Dave Reubens
fundamental beliefs about a number of
political issues I thought it was an
interesting interview tomorrow on the
program we are doing something similar I
will be joined for the hour by Professor
Peter Bogosian we are going to talk
about white privilege he wrote an
article arguing that white privilege
does not exist I believe that white
privilege does exist I believe is
someone who is actually personally a
Hispanic immigrant from a religious
minority in the world to the United
States because I am perceived as white I
can identify specific ways in which I
have
fitted from white privilege even though
it's unclear whether I'm white
I don't know according to the US census
it doesn't really seem like I'm white
doesn't matter though we're gonna talk
about that we're going to talk about
epistemology we are going to talk about
so many other things so tomorrow Peter
Boghossian will join me for the full
hour and our core political stories
including the firing of Anthony
scaramouche II will actually be on
tomorrow's bonus show so yet another
reason to become a member because
tomorrow every once in a while when we
do these hour-long interviews the
regular political stories are relegated
to the bonus show and tomorrow will be
one of those days okay eat KitKat double
J has sent a $2 Super chat saying no I
didn't mean just YouTube revenue I meant
all revenue and the for Michael Wood jr.
the for Michael Wood jr. Michael Wood
jr. was on the program today and it was
a really good interview and that will be
live on YouTube soon we've got a $5
super chat from mystic resistance who
says David have you ever done any shows
on the anti-authoritarian Pirate Party
movement in Europe it seems to be the
first truly 12th century political
movement I have not but I will make a
note right now to look that up after the
live stream is over and see what that's
all about gr has sent a $10 super chat
Pakman you were the one who said
polarity okay so I grabbed a 40 of
Schlitz bull ice and then another and
then whipped out my new cheque card
Frank macwrite I love you love gr quite
a love affair between gr and a lot of
people involved with the show and super
chatters and and all that stuff
Frank macwrite who sent a $20 super
check
I've asked about Trump's habits carrying
forward to future candidates but do you
see more politicians turning to Twitter
to speak to people since Trump has
started this trend I don't agree with
the method but I'm curious I do and
we've seen the French president
increasingly using Twitter we've seen
the Argentinian president who I follow I
follow our Gen Tinian politics very
closely since I was born there and a lot
of my family is there and he
president Macri is also using Twitter
yes I do see it as something that is
going to happen but as we saw there are
limits to government by Twitter Donald
Trump last week tweeted the new policy
on transgender military servicemembers
and that policy was they're not allowed
to serve in any capacity then the
Pentagon started fielding questions
about well how will you figure out who's
currently transgender in the military
what will the policy be blah blah blah
blah blah and the Pentagon said Donald
Trump tweeting is not a policy directive
and we've not actually deceived received
a policy directive from Donald Trump so
we're not doing anything for now so I
think that we are quickly finding out
the limits to Twitter and governing
Hobbiton has sent a five British Pound
superjet have you read any books by ein
Rand Paul Ryan and the gops personal
goddess and could I convince you to do a
deep dive video on her I would I might
be able to be convinced to do a deep
dive video on Iran I've read a couple
chapters of a couple of her books I was
actually at a talk radio conference
years ago and a publisher of iron ran
books was just giving them away and I
found them to be basically unreadable I
mean I rarely put books down I pick
books carefully and once I select them
I will typically stick with it and I was
not able to get through it I mean I just
was not able to get through it Aaron
Cohen sends a ten Canadian dollar super
chat I caught the Dave Rubin interview
you asked all the right questions and
exposed his knack of lack of knowledge
on specific policy issues he wrapped the
noose around his own neck great job
David you know Aaron not everybody
agrees with you some people do believe
that Dave Rubin was given enough rope to
hang himself with during that interview
others believe I just don't understand
classical liberalism I will be putting
out a deep dive on classical liberalism
during our vacation and maybe that will
prove to some that I do understand
classical liberalism maybe it is they
who don't understand it mystic
resistance has sent a $2 Super chat
I meant that the pirate party is a 21st
century movement I bad okay point taken
mystic I will check that out I will
into that let's continue to do some
thank you so the big picture of the and
bite by the big picture I don't mean a
big picture of my hair we are trying to
get to two thousand patreon patrons and
if and when we do and I believe it's a
matter of when not if although tomorrow
is August first which will cause a lot
of our patrons to fall off because their
credit cards will have expired over the
last month which is sad but when we get
to 2,000 patrons I have agreed to do an
entire broadcast show with my hair
looking like this now this is scary to a
lot of children and there's questions as
to whether it would violate the FCC's
policy on indecent content because this
could be indecent and also profane in
some ways but I have committed to doing
an entire broadcast show from our
broadcast studio with my hair like this
when we get to 2,000 patrons and we are
inching closer to that we started with
one of 1848 when we started the
livestream and we've had a number of
people make pledges Anastasia has just
edited her pledge from two to five
dollars a month thank you very much
Nathaniel kab Ilona has made a pledge of
five dollars a month and Morgan Ray Hess
has just made a pledge of two dollars a
month two dollars a month a dollar a
month
five dollars a month we are not talking
about big sums of money here but it adds
up we've got nearly 400,000 YouTube
subscribers
if merely five percent of them made a
pledge of a dollar a month I never
mentioned the YouTube ad boycott again
because it will not matter because we
will have made up all of the lost
YouTube ad revenue for today if we get
to 1860 I will create and release just
for you a 56 percent membership coupon
code I won't tell anybody else about it
just you on this stream and that will be
a major major thing we are only six new
patrons away from that if we get six
more new patrons and I really hope we
don't fail this time we did last time
then I will create that coupon code just
for you as far as memberships go
I want to thank Elizabeth Peron who has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership I want to thank Chris Cecile
who has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership and i also want to
thank aaron Hallman all of whom have
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership if you want a discount off of
your membership I say with peace and
love
take the discount and you can do that
with the coupon code I voted 17 now
here's just a possibility if you really
want a big discount go to patreon and
pledge $1 a month and then once we get
to the eighteen hundred and sixty
patrons use the 56% discount code that I
am six patrons away from creating and
then you get an even more discounted
membership it's sort of the best of both
worlds let's jump back into other
questions because there are many of them
engi binky 2000 has sent a five-dollar
super chat what percentage of hey tree
'it's do you think our actual fans just
trying to make the show I think it's a
low percentage engi bengi because uh
well you know I don't really want to say
what our system is for screening for
what is real hatred mail and what is
fake hate reott mail from fans trying to
get on the show but we have a number of
systems in place and let's just say it's
possible that some fake hate rillette
males get through but by and large I'm
pretty confident with our with our
screening system mystic resistance is
sent to $5 superjet David are you
following the recent India China
military standoff it's scary I think
China sees the weakness of the US with
Trump and are taking advantage I have
actually been following the India China
escalation and it is very and I think
that there is no doubt listen when you
see a precipitous decline in the number
of people around the world that see the
u.s. as the leader on X or as the
country to turn to on Y or Donald Trump
as the the so-called leader of the free
world which is not a literal
pronunciation a literal term but it sort
of represents the most powerful
Democratic Western country is sort of
the way it's often assessed that's going
to have a real impact and increased
belligerence the perception that they
can get one over on the United States is
going to lead to changes in policy and
changes in action by other countries and
while I don't think it's totally
responsible for it mystic I think you're
right in saying that there's an element
of that there's definitely an element of
that with what's going on in India and
China
Matthieu good tell has sent a
five-dollar super Chad would you
consider doing a debate similar to Genk
and Ann Coulter's recent debates I would
have done debates before and somebody
earlier asked about possibly attending
politican which I would consider doing
the timing of it didn't work out this
year I wasn't asked to participate in
one of these debates anyway but if I
were I would definitely be up for
checking that out no doubt about it and
you know my concern is I times wonder if
those debates are of limited
informational value it's it's more like
the optics and people like to see
arguments but as anyone's mind really
changed you've got people cheering for
each side and I know it makes for good
it makes for good videos and controversy
and tweet fights and whatever but I
don't know how much we gain from it but
I'm not against doing a debate merely
for publicity and then people will
follow the show and hopefully then they
learn in more detail about political
issues so yeah I'm not against doing it
TJ has sent a five British pound super
chat loving your show daily from the
United Kingdom Trump and brexit are the
two biggest fails in current Western
politics drama everyday with both thanks
right-wingers yeah fair point I was in
London at the end of December and my
first time in the United Kingdom and it
was a really really great trip learned a
lot got to see my cousin who's living in
the outskirts of London and it was a
great trip my one complaint and I'm
guessing this is not an unusual
complaint was that the cuisine was not
the best I did have arguably the best
Indian food that I have ever had in my
life in London I went to de su for
Indian style breakfast Bombay style
breakfast fantastic and I went to a
couple of other places and that was
really great but the cuisine was not the
highlight but the museums and the
historical sites all fantastic oh and
continuing the trend KLM sending a to
British pound super chat saying
greetings from Edinburgh Scotland love
the show I have never been to Scotland
but I am very interested in visiting
phobos moon has sent a five Canadian
dollar super chat have you heard about
the Omar Khadr settlement up here in
Canada do you have any opinions about it
you know I did hear about it and I'm not
remembering exactly what the details
were oh oh ma R Kotter is a Canadian
citizen detained by the u.s. at Gitmo
for 10 years from the age of 16 during
which he pleaded guilty to the murder of
US Army sergeant first class Christopher
spear and other charges pleaded guilty
later retracted yeah I have not read
about the details of that sediment but
it's a little settlement but I am
familiar with the story so that is
something I will look into okay let's go
back to a few more thank yous thank yous
to new David Pakman show members we have
a number of new members that have signed
up and for whatever reason I am unable
to pull up the list because my laptop is
tweaking a little bit why is my laptop
tweaking that is the real question and I
unfortunately don't have the answer to
that okay let me get back to the
membership thank-yous in a bit we are
trying to get to 1860 patrons by the end
of this stream if we get to 1860 patrons
before the end of the stream I will
create a custom coupon code which will
only be announced to you as a viewer of
this live stream which will give you a
fifty six percent discount off of
membership that will be the biggest
discount we will have ever done off of
membership if it succeeds we have a $5 a
month pledge from Karina sterner and
thanks to that pledge we are now five
patrons away from one thousand
860 the timing I am I've got about 15
minutes left unless livestream help us
get there I don't want to have another
failed attempt for a major membership
discount we're only 5 patrons away even
a dollar a month we'll do it okay and
then I will I will create and release
that coupon code help us out let's just
get it over with I'll create the coupon
code and then we can move on to more
politics
christina has sent a $2 super chat I'd
love to see you debate at politican love
the show all right well if I'm in you
know I don't know that that anybody
wants me there I don't know that
politican wants me there but if they
invite me for next year or I don't know
how you get invited or if you were
supposed to make a proposal I have no
idea I am willing to do it
engi bengi mm is back with a $10 super
chat I think the best thing you've ever
done was the dissection of reza aslan
how come not give other media
personalities who spread for lack of a
better term [ __ ] how come not give
other I guess you're saying why not do
that for other people we just haven't
done it yet I guess I don't have a
particularly good answer we just have
not done that yet although it's
certainly something that we we should do
we have a long form deep dive coming up
into classical liberalism we've got one
into the so called violet left we've got
another long-form piece coming up about
we've got so many that even I've
forgotten I should really pull up the
list because we've got it we've got a
lot of them coming up we've got one
coming up on socialism never having
worked which is a popular talking point
from some now I am NOT a socialist but
it is it is just wrong to say that
socialism has never worked we've got a
voter fraud long-form piece got a lot of
really good stuff really really good
stuff coming up okay
Giggs has sent a five-dollar super chat
as someone who got my high school degree
online I feel that education is lacking
from the net neutrality discussion in
how crucial the Internet is
yeah the Internet at this point it's
hard to agree it's hard to believe that
the internet shouldn't be regulated as a
as a public utility as a common carrier
at this point and when you think about
how much even forgetting about the
things that are done on the Internet by
end-users when you think about how much
business is transacted as a result of
the Internet I don't know how you argue
that it's not similar to what telephone
has become and I think that education is
a part of that gigs so thanks for
bringing that up
Canyon Bunny has sent a $2 super chat
how do you keep calm when you interview
guests yeah I get asked that about why
what why don't I get more upset and
start yelling at my guests or whatever I
mean well none of us are going to learn
anything if it just becomes a shouting
match and I I mean I think staying calm
is more mostly about not taking the
comments personally if they're directed
at me and assuming that the person just
doesn't understand what they're talking
about right I believe that most people
are not coming from a place of being bad
people but they are genuinely clueless
about a lot of things very important
things to quote our great orange leader
so I think that that and just practice I
mean you know I spend time preparing for
these interviews and researching so what
would sort of be a waste of time to then
start the interview and not actually ask
the questions and go through the
arguments and instead start yelling at
the person I'm interviewing you know it
just doesn't really make sense barry
bostwick has sent a five-dollar super
chatter dave rubin mentioned liberal
indoctrination on college campuses in
the hard sciences he probably means
science conservatives dislike like
climate change etc yeah I mean here's
the thing just pointing out that college
professors are heavily liberal rather
than conservative is not evidence of
bias because many fields lend themselves
to
more progressive ideology and would be
off-putting to conservatives so I that
alone now that's not an argument to say
that there isn't a problem with
left-wing bias on campuses there you
could make that argument you could make
the argument in whatever field you want
you have to then demonstrate that merely
saying 80% of college professors are
liberal that's not evidence of bias
that's that that's evidence that
teaching college is a profession and you
can break it down further into
departments if you want that appeals
more to progressives in the same way
that I don't know people who own big
construction companies tend to be more
conservative for example does that mean
that the construction industry is
conservatively biased in some systemic
way or does it mean that the profession
lends itself more to conservatism now I
know the argument you'll make which is
well real construction businesses aren't
indoctrinating anyone or influencing
people's political beliefs whereas
professors are that's a fair point that
that's a fair point but the the point
I'm making is that pointing out that
there is a disproportionate number of
progressives teaching college is not
evidence of liberal indoctrination
synthesizer demos has sent the $5 super
check can you ask Peter Boghossian why
he thinks that publishing his conceptual
penis article in a pay-to-play Journal
is a valid critique of gender study
scholars I haven't note about that you
know I am going to talk about gender
studies and his views on gender studies
tomorrow but I don't know if will
specifically come at it from that angle
okay but I will note put that in my
notes
Liyana rose LLS Leonie Rose I don't know
how to pronounce it ll s I sent a $2
super chat with no question or comment
all right
how close are we to 1860 patrons if we
reach 1860 patrons at patreon.com slash
david pakman show in the eight minutes
we have left of this live stream I will
create a 56 % discount code for
membership and you will reap the fruits
of that coupon code Lauren Thomas has
just pledged $1 a month
been Hege has just pledged two dollars a
month John has just pledged five dollars
a month Eyvind VAM so I probably
butchered that has pledged six dollars a
month Kenyan Bunny has pledged five
dollars a month and John Moore Bee has
just pledged $2 a month which has
achieved 1860 patrons in fact it has
achieved 1861 patrons so mark my words I
said I would do it and I'm going to do
it I am going to announce to you a 56
percent discount code off of any
membership you like you can keep that
discounted price for as long as you want
I think the coupon code should be
related to Scarah Moochie okay what
should it be
maybe all right here we go the coupon
code for 56 percent off of your
membership is by mooch 17 all one word
coupon code for 56 percent off by mooch
17 that's be ye MOOC h17 that coupon
code will expire when will it expire
it'll expire tomorrow okay so feel free
to use that code that will save you 56
percent off of membership thanks to
Jennifer Senath who has also thrown in
another $2.00 a month pledge and thanks
also to grace
Coggins who has signed up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership
this is the biggest discount that i have
ever offered so take advantage of it
because it will be gone by the end of
tomorrow and I will do I will continue
to do thank yous as people use that
coupon code you have only yourselves to
thank great people of the livestream
game fire 74 has sent a 12 dollar and 72
cents super chat John Oliver's show was
about how Alex Jones is batshit crazy I
found it less disingenuous than Megan
Kelly should people not talk about or
not give him a platform
his madness known as important yeah I
don't believe in no platforming people I
believed when megyn kelly launched this
major new show and then her second guest
was Alex Jones I thought that it was
sort of a platform that he was not
worthy of but I don't believe in no
platforming people and I don't believe
in you know saying that someone whose
opinions are offensive should just never
be interviewed right I interviewed
people all the time with offensive
opinions but I do think it's important
to be adversarial when people say
horrible things megyn kelly did some of
that I have not yet seen the John Oliver
piece but I do want to watch it and I
bookmarked it and we'll check it out
tonight
saucy mix ah sir has sent a five
dollar-a-month super chat what's with
all the Canadian conservative media
personalities Lauren southern Gavin
McInnes steven crowder maybe cuz there's
a market down south yeah I don't know I
I genuinely don't know and same thing
sort of applies to the whole sargon of
akkad thing like why why is he all
wrapped up in American politics part of
it is a play for business right because
he gets much more attention talking
about American politics way more people
live in the u.s. than in the UK where he
is so hey I've got no problem though I
mean hey if the free market of online
media says people are interested in what
you're doing and there's financial
rewards for you to do it then by all
means do it there you go
okay people asking what are the benefits
of membership because we do have this 56
percent coupon code that you have earned
the coupon code is by mu CH 17 be ye
MOOC H 17 the biggest - member benefits
of are the bonus show every day we do an
hour broadcast show free to everybody
but we do an additional Members Only
bonus show only for paid subscribers and
if you're not a member the way we
publish our our show is we chop it up
into individual stories and publish them
to YouTube every hour and a half when
you remember you don't have to wait for
the clips to publish around 4:00 p.m.
Eastern Time you
get a members-only one-hour video of the
entire show and you can watch the entire
thing so those are those are the most
popular benefits of membership okay and
speaking of which let's do a few other
thank-yous
Ben Hege has signed up with the by mooch
17 coupon code Travis Burgess has signed
up with the by mooch 17 coupon code and
also we do have another patreon pledge
from Richard a Gil V Richard of York of
Gil V oh I'm sorry not a new pledge he
has edited his pledge from two up to
five dollars thank you very very much I
really do appreciate that and you know
what kind of sucks
tomorrow is August 1st and what happens
on patreon it's just such a it's such a
bummer every time it happens it's very
low energy is actually what I would
describe it throughout the month we grow
our number of Patriot patrons and this
month we've had significant growth we're
up to 1861 at last check on the first of
the month patreon goes to charge
everybody who has pledged and
unfortunately anywhere from 10 to 15% of
our patrons of all patrons their credit
cards may have expired during that prior
month their credit cards or debit cards
some people get declined pledges and so
what happens on the 1st of every month
is we lose like 10% of our pledges and
then we got to go back and start pushing
the boulder back up the hill on the 1st
of the month and because we've had such
growth in patreon during July I know I'm
gonna be bummed out tomorrow morning
tomorrow morning is gonna be a big
bummer
I don't know I don't know how else to
put it but that's okay we will continue
keep on we will keep keep on keeping on
or whatever the phrase is and
fortunately people are taking advantage
of that coupon code did I mention
Jennifer sent off Jennifer Santa has
signed up with the by mood 7
coupon code morgen Hess has signed up
with the coupon code scott davis has
signed up anastasia castile has signed
up with the coupon code and that's all
its major it's absolutely and utterly
major that that is going on and I really
really appreciate it
few more super chats to talk about Peter
Watkins has sent the ten dollar super
cheque can you go on Matt Christensen's
show Beauty and the beta you guys are
both well-reasoned political commenters
and both represent my political opinions
I have never heard of this show Beauty
and the beta yeah there it is
I don't know anything about it Matt
Christianson I have no I don't know
anything about it
but I'm open to considering it if I I
mean you know I want to make sure it's
worth it that that's the only thing I
try to avoid like tiny tiny podcast now
just because I can't do every podcast I
get invited to Ryan Couture has sent a
dollar super chat thanks very much and
John Foltz has sent a dollar super chat
thank you very much I really very much
appreciate that and on that note we will
wrap up this live stream by mu CH 17
saves you 56 percent off of membership
that's the biggest membership discount
code I've ever done
appreciate everybody who is signing up
more tomorrow in August